hey guys it's end of the vlog and today
on that BuzzFeed I'm taking their
millennial test which of these songs is
not by instinct bye bye bye
gonna be me Karen of my heart or I want
it that way I feel like I feel like I
want it that way it is not shy just
click it and see is it gonna tell me
right away it's gonna tell me that I
filled right away oh right oh I'm so
good look at me go
which show starred Zack Morris Boy Meets
World
Sabrina the Teenage Witch full house are
Saved by the Bell
my brain says Saved by the Bell but I
don't know ah hey Tess oh my gosh I'm
totally guessing movies what is this
phone call a flip phone no
Stephanopoulos of a sidekick but in me
chocolate or a brazier browser no I
don't know something that I've heard of
her I hate this lever I have to actually
take okay I bet you're a journalist
right oh my gosh which isn't away your
character what could die and boredom
trail game electrocution snake by
dysentery and measles what is a reason
ah I'm not a Roland I don't have break
this okay first frog its electrocution I
don't even know what the Oregon Trail is
so which of these apps did you use to
illegally download music illegally
download music all I've heard of MySpace
Spotify and iTunes but I've never heard
of LimeWire so logic or is that what
myspace was I don't know what myspace is
no maybe not I feel like I was like like
you go live or something on it
you talk to people on it what's up
everyone its anima bonk and welcome to
my myspace today we're going to be well
a lot and you know the rest
I'm gonna go LimeWire just cuz I don't
think he's gonna legally download music
on iTunes or Spotify and I don't think
that's what myspace is so it was right
jeez what kind of life did these ladies
live a simple life the sweet life the
hard-knock life the secret life know
something of the simple I don't know why
it's just like what my brain bakes so oh
my gosh you got it right Oh which celeb
did not get their big break on Disney
Channel
Hilary Duff Miley Cyrus Demi Lovato or
Amanda Bynes oh yeah I was gonna be very
upset if I didn't get that finish this
sentence see kind please unwind rewind
Grindr mind be kind please were wide
know no one would say that I don't know
I'm gonna go with mine
here we go I know we're like winking
it's your heard whine what he kind
please rewind Oh be kind because they
have to rewind it and that's kind what
product was this silhouette advertising
Furby Tamagotchi the Zune or iPod I
don't think it's Furby or an iPod look
it's the zoom you know I don't really
know what that is I'm just gonna guess
it was an iPod there's no iPod in this
thing which snack was not in a
millennial kids lunchbox a goer dunkers
zebra cakes or way sticks gogurts
probably were I love zebra cakes I hope
those were I don't know what a wish
stick is and I don't know what a dunker
is is you're like dung Kurds or
something or like it's more now kind of
thing I don't know I don't know the
logic - but I'm just gonna guess so
so with [ __ ] which of these movies do
make fetch happen wait I feel like I
know this oh my gosh I love Air Bud wait
hold on I feel like Oh everybody
clueless I've never seen clueless and I
feel like that's definitely a movie I
would say fetch it so it's Mean Girls
I've seen that one oh good finally the
last question finally which catalog then
millennial teen girls used to shop for
clothes I don't know boys alright yeah
that one's go lastic Circuit City or
Delia's like that might be it oh my gosh
I'm gonna go shop on Circuit City that
sounds good it's got a row the Delia
Delia thing I picked circuit seaweed you
are not a millennial 6 out of 12 we're
right that's half that's pretty good I'm
half a millennial okay that's how it
works but it's okay
[Music]